hi
hi so good to see all of you
congratulations happy press day
i mean i'm seeing there's press from
around the world talking to you today
you've been sitting there for a while
how does it feel for you to be able to
talk about season two
um
well still a little bit scary because
we're like can we say spoilers yeah
we're still nervous about spoilers
[Applause]
but it feels joy like an absolute you
know it's joyful celebration and it's
something that we've been keeping a
little secret and you work on it and
it's it's a love story so it's been
thrilling to you know to step into the
shoes and to tell kate and anthony's
story to share it now is great and and
also the show is just all about
positivity and representation and
allowing people to feel empowered and to
see themselves in these amazing sweeping
stories so of course now it's just like
amazing to be able to talk about it yeah
well i gotta tell you season two is kick
ass it is absolutely amazing i love
season one and season two just really
brightened my day and that's because of
samantha and terethra jonathan you're
great too but you know the fact there's
two south asian women leading the way in
the show i applaud you guys because this
is gonna have such an impact on so many
people out there do you realize the
impact you're gonna have on young girls
i didn't last year i think i was really
naive to it last year um i think now
um and i think i was maybe afraid of it
um yeah um
and i i think i'm learning so much more
now um you know what it is to represent
a minority on screen and
how we can how how we can share that
space and how much fun we can bring to
it and it doesn't have to be
scary to use your voice in that way to
um
to share that space i think um you know
working with aretha and getting to know
her for one and learning so much for her
um has made me
i guess
just
really um feel even more excited for the
ride that's to come so yeah
and have your family or friends seen it
simona charita
what did mom say
what was her reaction
i loved it
she was like especially ended up so sick
she was when the when it cut to the
credits she was like oh like she was
like no
next one she was like on the cliffhanger
mum loved it
i love it and jonathan you know we get
to see a lot more of the story of
anthony and you know he's carrying the
weight of the world on his shoulders and
uh trying to figure out love so i'm
curious what's your definition of love
very good
love is about
um understanding oneself and the other
person i think that's what this story of
love is you know he's there's a lot that
he has to overcome in order to be able
to love himself in order to then love
kate um so it's about i think it's about
esteem holding yourself and someone else
in high esteem and protecting that at
all costs that's what love is
oh that's nice i didn't expect that
that's wonderful
well said uh yeah so there's another
star in this uh season and that's the
dog newman i think everyone's in love
with him you know it's so awesome to
have him on the show so my question to
you simone did you prefer working with
the dog or lord bridgeton
or the dog
um
she's thinking about it
he i have to i mean he was a bit of an
old school dinosaur when it came to
working on the set he just didn't stunt
he didn't get accused i loved him though
he listened to him i'd like to think he
responded to me
i mean
[Laughter]
love that and cherithro why do you think
this show resonates with so many people
because it is about love it is about
marriage and it's about finding a
suitable guy so why is it resonating
with people in 2022
well i think that there are so many
elements and different people are
attracted to different elements of it of
course you know we have the traditional
sort of uh romance period loving
um audience but then also you know the
makeup and the hair and the costumes are
so inspiring people will watch it for
the beautiful like dance sequences yeah
i actually think that it came at a time
where everybody was looking for joy
everyone was looking for escapism and
then the final element i think is that
um
with the representation and diversity
that you see on screen i think that it
also diversifies the audience certainly
everyone loves to feel seen on screen
and when you have such a beautiful
multi-racial cast like we do
of course it's going to attract a
bigger audience and for so long you know
i think that
there's been like this consensus within
within the industry that like that's
something that's risky or that's going
to be unpopular and bridgeton's here to
tell you that it's quite frankly the
opposite no i love that
i'm so proud of you guys congratulations
to all of you season two is amazing i
can't wait for everyone to see it thank
you so much take care thanks everyone